lukom meine lieben freunde ich habe
schon lange keine rätsel auf
einem kanal gemacht und ich glaube dass
vermisst auch niemandem teilen zusammen
hey wir haben nachgedacht und
festgestellt dass wir lange zeit keine
rätsel hatten
[Musik]
die besten heute der welt
ihr habt euch wahrscheinlich schon daran
gewöhnt in entspannter atmosphäre am pc
zu sitzen und lustige videos anzuschauen
habe heute bieten wir an ein wenig das
gehirn anzuschalten das geht nicht weil
ich kein subgear sind fünf rätsel die
ihr lösen müsst um am leben zu bleiben
was es
heißt wenn ich eins falsch habe bin ich
tot wird das wird sehr interessant ihr
habt euch in einer höhle verliert stellt
euch vor ihr wert ein sehr cooler
fotograf und listet für ein berühmtes
magazin ein paar bilder von innen machen
wir haben uns in der höhle verirrt ich
für meinen teil würde erstmal gar nicht
in der höhle reingehen aber okay
zweite sache wir sind ein sehr cooler
fotograf
ja ich glaube ich soll einfach nicht
alles hinterfragen der tunnel aus dem
ihr kamt wurde von stein zugeschüttet du
warst nun nachdem wir euch um gesehen
habt bemerkt ihr fünf tunnel von denen
alle nach draußen führen aber in jedem
eine gefahr lauert der erste tunnel wird
von vampir fledermäusen bewohnt durch
vampirfledermäuse für logisch sobald ihr
in den zweiten tunnel geht erwartet euch
ein starker er tröt der euch sofort
begräbt im dritten tunnel ist der ganze
weg mit glühender lava gefüllt die eure
kleidung und euch in wenigen minuten
zerschmelzen wird der vier tunnel ist
mit giftigen gas gefüllt dass alle tiere
tötet die es wagen da rein zu gelangen
und im fünften tunnel blühen radioaktive
pflanzen die blitzartig durch eine
strahlendosis töten können also mal ganz
kurz
fragen wie diese pflanzen in einer höhle
wo kein tageslicht es überleben die
frage woher weiß ich dass diese nicht
überhaupt stecken gerne dritte frage da
kann ja gar nicht sein dass jeder im
herbst erneut ohne deinen dies mit
gerade mal 39 48 hat genau da ein
abkommen wird also es macht ihr absolut
gar nichts sind wohl angehen um lebend
herauszukommen
ich bin ganz ehrlich
ich würde das casting nehmen alle
optionen außer der vierten werden zu
einem tödlichen ausgang führen
ich habe nur das casting team um weil
alle anderen vier sachen überhaupt
keinen sinn für mich ergeben haben dass
es überhaupt stattfinden kann in dieser
höhle warum der vierte da gibt es doch
das giftige gas fragt ihr weil er sich
nämlich nur auf tiere negativ auswirkt
und wir glauben kaum dass er einst seit
ich bin ein tier also einerseits wegen
massiven muskel aber andererseits sind
menschen generell tiere
aber gut man mal wieder mit dem nächsten
rätsel jetzt seid ihr ein verirrter
tourist und wurde von einem stamm von
eingeborenen gefangen genommen sie laden
die überhaupt nicht leiden können aber
irgendwie sind sie höflich und haben
euch das recht zu wählen und das letzte
wort überlassen ganz kurze andere frage
warum werden diese stammes bewohner
irgendwelchen film- doku- cz rapper so
dargestellt als
wenn ihr nichts besseres zu tun haben
sich den ganzen tag irgendwelche
komischen strich ins gesicht zu machen
wenn ihr also bei ihrer letzten rede
liegt werdet ihr mit einem gewehr
erschossen kleine die wahrheit sagt
landet ihr auf dem scheiterhaufen er es
scheint dass die situation hoffnungslos
ist aber denkt sorgfältig nach denn
sicher könnt ihr die wilden mit nur
einem satz über listen und am leben
bleiben einfach die wahrheit sagen
der dann sehen jedoch dass ich ehrlich
bin
ich würd ich wird die wahrheit sagen
alles ist eigentlich sehr einfach man
kann mit einer einzigen phrase die
gauner in eine sackgasse locken okay ihr
müsst nur sagen dass ihr euch mit einer
pistole töten werden was ist der haken
ihr behauptet dass ihr euch auf diese
weise töten werden wahrscheinlich sind
die eingeborenen schon bereit das gewehr
zu laden weil sie euch auf diese weise
töten könnten doch wartet mal wenn ihr
die wahrheit sagt solltet ihr auf dem
scheiterhaufen geröstet werden aber hier
ist ein gewehr was soll man denn tun
das ist das tollste chris was ich mir
angeschaut ab dieses mal hat es euch auf
der obersten etage eines gebäudes
erwischt das gleich abgerissen werden
soll deswegen keine hilfe ihr wurde mit
eurem unglück allein gelassen es gibt
keine treppen keine fenster aber aufzüge
zur wahl sie sind der einzige weg zur
rettung bereit aber vorsichtig im ersten
aufzug safe riesenspinnen
ich sag's euch da kommen 100 prozent
befindet sich eine sehr
ich kann gar nicht so viel und der
schacht des zweiten aufzugs ist bis oben
mit kochendem wasser gefüllt was in den
aufzug durch sichert und euch sofort
kochen werden im dritten aufzug werdet
ihr auf moskito stoßen die träger von
gefährlichen krankheiten sind dessen
gegenmittel sehr schwer zu besorgen sind
was werdet ihr dieses mal wählen also
war ganz kurz wir haben eine extrem
riesige spinne wo ich auf gar keinen
fall drängen werde bei ich hasse spinnen
und dann haben wir nur noch ein aufzug
nummer zwei das kochende wasser und
aufzug nummer drei die moskitos
natürlich nehme ich die 2
ein aufzug hat immer irgendwo lücken
oder keine ahnung was so dass das wasser
daraus geht oder ich klettere oben dann
durch das wasser durch auf den aufzug
drauf und fährt darunter safe 2 hier
glauben dass sie die richtige wahl
getroffen hat die kabine mit moskitos
erstens wenn ihr pech gehabt und
gebissen werden ist die chance ein
gegenmittel zu finden klein aber immer
noch da ja wer nicht
nach der wahl scheiß drauf nichts dreht
sich hass insekten ihr seid in einem
dunklen raum in einem käfig
eingeschlossen aufgewacht okay von
irgendwoher kommt eine stimme und sagt
dass er mit euch ein spiel spielen will
das ist ja mein albtraum nach der käfig
öffnet sich der countdown beginnt zu
laufen und drei türen erscheinen für
euch hinter der ersten von ihnen
befindet sich ein serienmörder dem jahr
1890 300 menschen getötet hatte ok ja
der zweiten gibt es bewegungssensoren
die am eingang die freisetzung von
flüssigem stickstoff aktivieren der euch
ein bruchteil von einer sekunde
einfrieren wird und hinter der dritten
tür wartet eine säure dusche unter der
man nicht überleben kann aber sich
wunderbar in flüssigem zustand versetzen
kann welche tierwelt hier zur rettung
ist total einfach
wenn er serienmörder 1890 traube
menschen getötet hat dann ist doch jetzt
schon längst tot also eins habt ihr die
richtige wahl getroffen ich dafür ist
die option nummer 1 daran hier
aufmerksam zugehört habt müsst ihr
erkannt haben dass sich der mörder der
sich dahinter versteckt sich längst in
ein skelett verwandelt hat und euch kein
schaden zufügen wird
letztere ich das komplette video
durchgespielt habt zwar nicht öfter
richtig aber gut für das ende haben wir
das schwierigste rätsel vorbereitet
lösung ihr wahrscheinlich mehr zeit
brauchen werdet als für alle anderen
zusammen natürlich möchten wir nicht
dass sie in diese situation sei und hält
euch vor dass ihr blind und krank seid
blind und krank und ich brauche
wahrscheinlich medikamente und musste
irgendwie auseinander halten ihre ganzen
rätsel videos und alle gleich aufgebaut
darüber hinaus seid ihr in einer wohnung
ohne kommunikationsmittel eingeschlossen
um ihre gesundheit zu erhalten müsst ihr
am tag zwei tabletten nehmen und rot
insgesamt habt ihr zwei stück jeder art
wenn ihr mehr als zwei nehmt werdet ihr
sterben klar
theologisch sind jetzt zwei gleich
hinnimmt werdet ihr sterben logo hier
waren die pillen in verschiedenen
gläsern aber ihr seid blind eine
ungeschickte bewegung und sie sind alle
durcheinander gekommen wie soll man in
solch einer situation vorgehen denn ihr
braucht die medizin darüber hinaus sind
alle tabletten in form und textur
absolut identisch okay das wäre als
meine idee gewesen oder liegt auch
bisschen mickrig aus ich habe viel zu
viel angst vor viel zu vielen dingen sie
können dich durch berührungen
unterschieden werden und jetzt ist es
zeit zu überlegen euer leben hängt davon
ab also ganz kurz wir müssen täglich
eine blauen eine rote nehmen und dann
nochmal eine blaue rote man kann weder
zwei blaue unternehmen noch zwei rote
hintereinander nehmen
ich würde ein das prinzip hier sind uns
einig dass dieses rätsel alles andere
als einfach ist aber auch eine logische
lösung die wird auf gar keinen fall
logisch sein das kann jetzt schon sagen
und kein fehler bei der entscheidung zu
machen müsst ihr jede der vier tabletten
nacheinander halbieren und das
zerbrochene stück beiseite legen damit
sich nichts vermischt am ende erhaltet
ihr zwei handvoll vier hälften jetzt
könnt ihr ohne probleme alle fünften von
jeder hand einnehmen weil die hälften
jeweils ein ganzes rotes und ein ganzes
blaues bilden werden das habe ich
einfach nicht verstanden gerade
aber das ist auch komplett egal denn ich
bin generell einfach komplett blöd an
der stelle mich das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden wenn er liegen
freude wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
echt mein beileid wenn ihr besten
content sehen wollte meine lieben
freunde dann schaut euch doch gern
dieses video hier an das ist nämlich ein
video das geändert ist sobald sich meine
freundin peyton erschreckt hat habe ich
auf meinem 2 kanal hochgeladen linz mit
ihrer eingeblendet könnt ihr auch gerne
mal vorbeischauen da lade ich aktuell
täglich videos hoch solche videos dienen
sondern richtung auch gehen also
eigentlich komplette scheiße lassen